On the 4th of March 1890, the Forth Bridge in Scotland,...
...which featured the longest cantilever bridge span in the world at the time,...
...was opened by the future King Edward VII.
The Forth Bridge stretches almost two and a half kilometers across the Firth of Forth,...
...a large estuary area to the west of Edinburgh.
The bridge, which features two main spans of over 500 meters each,...
...continues to operate as a vital rail link between Fife and the Lothians.
The Forth Bridge was designed by the English engineers Sir John Fowler...
...and Sir Benjamin Baker using the cantilever principle,...
...in which a central span is supported by the tension and compression...
...of supporting arms that are only anchored at one end.
The bridge was finally completed in December 1889...
...and was tested the following month to ensure that it operated properly under load.
Satisfied that the bridge was safe,...
...the chairmen of the various railway companies...
....involved in funding the 3.2-million-pound construction,...
...traveled over it several times on the 24th of February.
A week later, the future King Edward VII formally opened the bridge...
...and secured the last of six and a half million rivets.
The bridge continues to carry more than 200 trains a day...
...and is an important symbol of Scotland.